[Music]
something that happened here at the show
in my personal life that's kind of
uncomfortable and what what is that okay
it's this someone someone bought my wife
this beautiful expensive Christmas gift
it is a really fancy scarf these things
are very expensive and all the card says
is thinking of you Clark Clark Clark and
I was thinking about it the only Clark I
know is our cameraman guilty as charged
going
okay well Clark you gave my wife this
scarf
not just any Scot it's a hand-woven silk
armées made in Paris the kind of scarf
that says you're a special lady and
someone noticed Clark this is entirely
inappropriate well did you like it
that's the important thing
no Clark the important thing is for you
to respect boundaries hard to draw
boundaries around the human heart I just
want her to be happy
Clark she is happy well doesn't seem
like it in their facebook status updates
[Music]
your your Facebook friends with my wife
just poked it
all right listen creep leave my wife
alone and take care of your own wife
yeah crap I forgot about her I didn't
thanks Larry
don't mention it well I see you and
Bonnie and my hot tub later already
wearing my trunks can't wait to take
them off you know you guys are pretty
much the same person aren't you
that's probably why this sketch is
ending so well it's not ending that well
I think your wife might like it
[Applause]
by the way by the way I'm also on
steroids
I hate that guy
if only I had the power to fire that guy
here at Conan nope I'm out of here on a
volunteer basis just to meet you what he
is he's a terrible camera there's a town
over
yeah let's actually camera take Howard
show porno the sketch actor's real
camera angle right now
yeah okay
[Music]
let's see I know what I got catch on
quick as he gets better as a cameraman
he gets worse as things at the same time